c'est un exercice imposé pour chaque
président français ya quelques jours du
soixantième anniversaire du premier
essai nucléaire français
le chef de l'état chef des armées et
s'est exprimée devant un parterre
d'officiers à l'école de guerre à paris
comme ses prédécesseurs à l'elysée
emmanuel macron a donc détaillé sa
vision de la dissuasion nucléaire
française allait considérer par la
france comme la clé de voûte de cette
stratégie de défense
dans un contexte de remise en cause des
traités existants par les états unis et
la russie
le chef de l'état propose aux européens
un dialogue stratégique
il souhaite que les européens soient
associés à de futures négociations sur
les forces nucléaires de portée
intermédiaire écoutez nous force
nucléaire joue un rôle dissuasif propres
notamment en europe
elle renforce la sécurité de l'europe
par leur existence même est à cet égard
ont une dimension authentiquement
européenne notre indépendance de
décision est pleinement compatible avec
une solidarité inébranlable à l'égard de
nos partenaires européens
dans cet esprit je souhaite que se
développe un dialogue stratégique avec
nos partenaires européens qui sont prêts
sur le rôle de la dissuasion nucléaire
française dans notre sécurité collective
les partenaires européens qui souhaitent
s'engager sur cette voie pourront être
associés aux exercices des forces
françaises de dissuasion emmanuel macron
qui a réitéré la nécessité d'impliquer
la russie l'objectif principal
j'y suis revenu à plusieurs reprises de
ma démarche à l'égard de la russie
c'est l'amélioration des conditions de
la sécurité collective et de la
stabilité de l'ordre
ce processus s'étalera sur plusieurs
années
il demandera à patience et exigences et
il sera conduit avec nos partenaires
européens mais nous
avons aucun intérêt à déléguer un tel
dialogue ou à nous enfermer dans la
situation actuelle